i got a little surprise for you tonight  and  of course  you may want to sit down  that when you feel like standing up you  just go right ahead and stand up again  okay  so um  yes  my name is bruce cohen and  mrs donna and mr b  asked me to come here tonight because  my friend don mishra and i are the  producers of  coming this february the 83rd annual  academy awards  who knows another name for the academy  awards  okay now i have a little harder question  about two weeks ago  we announced who the hosts are gonna be  for this year's oscars who knows  now  ps22 do you want to eat one of them  wow you guys are incredible  hollywood well i am here  to officially invite you guys  all  friday february 25th we'll be flying you  to los angeles  is  you have to go to the red carpet  83rd  about um years